[Musique]
j'adore
ses paysages je n'ai que faire des
paysans me coûte déjà ce cher nelly
cette maison est la propriété de l'état
nord
j'aurais jamais dû quitter l'irlande les
anglais paieront pour ça c'est vrai ce
qu'on raconte
au sujet du prisonnier vous le
connaissez c'était le meilleur soldat
que j'aie jamais rencontré
vous courez un grave danger qui rendra
justice à ma famille si je le fais pas
c'est donc vous qui sont envoyées
je te ramène arrêt marque office
vous mettez pas en travers de mon chemin
[Musique]
il
au wagon beyond the white house
[Musique]
/
bastien
vous
si sa tante je fais un concert classique
au début des vacances carrément c ou en
italie à venise
j'aimerais trouille et les gilles bien
meilleure idée
on va y aller tous ensemble à venir
c'est ce qu'a bien avec notre carte tout
hasard et avec les dingues moteur est en
surchauffe à cause de la caravane
voiture comme des beignets la balle
garagiste qui m'a donné ce truc là il
faut mettre le chauffage à fond et ça
fait froid dans notre porte
[Musique]
bonjour aux problèmes chez combat non
bah ma main la finisse parlons un peu de
ton père tu sais pourquoi il est
interdit de sortir de la forêt est ce
qu'il t'a dit où il montait à les sommes
tous très inquiet pour lui disais
tout va bien maintenant elle simule
sortez de là tout de suite richard
tu m'entraîne pour que je devienne une
machine et tu veux que je reste là
pourquoi il faudra qu'on la trouve à
fort kent outreau
si quelqu'un pose des questions on n'a
jamais vu cette fin vous sentez en
danger avec elle parce que les gens
veulent me faire du mal et n'y a que mon
père qui peuvent exiger tout ce que je
veux c'est que tu me fasses confiance
[Musique]
je peux faire confiance à personne pour
2 9 heures
[Musique]
je voulais offrir une vie normale
pourtant je suis pas quelqu'un normal
se tuer
[Musique]
c'est peut être si sûr
emmenez là deux fois
d'où est ce que tu viens en fait
pourquoi je trouve bizarre c'est ça non
je te trouve magnifique à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est leur lève toi formaté
wayana vous savez qu'elle est dangereuse
[Musique]
moi non plus je veux pas te perdre à
témoin vous n'avez aucune idée de ceux à
qui vous avez affaire
plus de secret pourquoi pourquoi ils me
veulent moi
[Musique]
jusqu'où
je le sentais vraiment terrorisés
comme un renard coincés au fond de son
terrier
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais la méthode des
lieux je connais pas le royaume de la
mémoire tout ça lorsque nous sommes en
ce moment